on va parler un peu plus de donald trump
avec vous frédéric parce que c'est quand
même bon un candidat à l'investiture
républicaine extrêmement controversée
même au sein de son propre parti on le
voit et il a surtout investi dans
l'immobilier cet homme effectivement
c'est un personnage là c'est coloré donc
un homme d'affaires de 60,9 en fait qui
a commencé sa carrière avec l'aide de
son père évidemment qu'il y avait une
déjà une entreprise de gestion
d'appartements locatifs dans les
quartiers de new york
donc il est entrée dans les affaires
familiales et depuis effectivement il
est de plus en plus investi dans
l'immobilier suffit de penser par
exemple à la fameuse prime tower la new
york qui fait plus de 2 100 mètres
cinquante trois étages il ya les casinos
à las vegas mais aussi atlantic city ou
encore les tours résidentielles à
vancouver et toronto et partout où il
passe il ya toujours le fameux nom sur
chacun des édifices
si on regarde maintenant par exemple ce
qui fait en télévision on le sait il
s'est beaucoup investi là-dedans a dit
apprentice à une émission de
télé-réalité pendant une dizaine
d'années il salue rapporté à peu près 15
millions de dollars par épisode jusqu'à
un certain point donc c'est quand même
un businessman assez incroyable y avait
aussi les chaudes miss univers sa
fortune serait estimé à 4 milliards de
dollars selon forbes
et il vient de publier ses revenus pour
2014 il a reçu de 362 millions $ qui
vient de 168 sources différentes donc il
est très diversifiée ouais il veut faire
le ménage des finances aux états unis
mais son passé de mauvais gestionnaires
resurgit un peu oui en fait quand on
regarde justement sur son cv l'oeil un
palmarès qui est pas forcément glorieux
en fait il a fait 4 faillite
en 18 ans par exemple le trump taj mahal
un énorme casino et là il s'est endetté
de 3 milliards de dollars pour celui là
il ya eu également trump plaza hôtel en
92 550 millions de dollars de dettes
il y avait également le trump hotel and
casino resort là encore on perd
quasiment 2 milliards de dollars et il y
avait aussi à d'autres entreprises bref
c'est pas très reluisant mais ce qu'il
dit toujours je n'ai jamais fait de
faillite personnelle et c'est vrai
puisque en fait il s'est toujours placé
sous la fameuse loi sur les faillites là
la fameuse loi 11 aux états unis qui
permet de se restructurer sans jamais
devoir fermer des entreprises alors pour
les américains il aime ce genre de
message parce que finalement c'est
quelqu'un qui a échoué mais qui lui
rebondit toujours plus et c'est ce qui
fait partie du fameux rêve américain
et ça lui permet évidemment d'avoir de
l'or du temps d'antenne gratuit et donc
de faire valoir ses idées évidemment qui
ne sont pas toujours très reluisant le
très populaire chez les républicains
utiliser les couleurs et très populiste
merci frédéric